hi y'all i'm ready for this to be really
embarrassing for me
first celebrity crush it was actually
daphne ruben vega from rent that was a
cool not awkward moment when i met her
for the first time ever in real life i
was sweating i was like oh you're so
amazing and beautiful i used to have a
picture of you on my wall i'm so sorry
this is weird but it was also awesome of
course i mentioned to daphne that she
was my crush and i did it in the most
awkward way possible which is like just
you know right up my alley i was like
daddy i love you right in her face which
was awesome and made for a really really
not awkward rehearsal environment at all
she likes me now though the question is
the first time i realized i was famous
and i don't think of myself as famous
like when i think of famous people i
think of like terry crews who can't walk
down the street without people being
like derek you know i am lucky that i
can sort of put on a hat and hide away
if someone were to recognize me but like
the first time that someone kind of came
up to me and burst into tears was really
special and it was a young queer kid and
they told me how much seeing me on tv
being a member of the bi community as
rosa meant to them and how it helped
them have a conversation with their
family and help them come out and that
was really really special i'll never
forget that i haven't had a first wild
and crazy fan experience so if you're
listening to this you could be the first
most of the fans that i've run into have
been really nice generous awesome cool
people that i'd probably want to be
friends with my first reaction when i
found out that i was voicing a new
disney character shock and awe all
combined into one with a little sprinkle
of dreams come true i lost my mind
pretty much as they say in the magazines
i was over the moon but i really was i
felt like everything that i'd been
working on and working so hard for and
dreaming about had actually come true
and i couldn't really believe it was
real i'm mostly excited for people to
see enganto because i think the story is
so incredible and i think the music is
so amazing i think the animation is
beyond anything i could have ever
imagined but i'm also excited because
then it'll mean it's actually really
real because i kind of still can't
believe that it is anybody can be a
heroine it doesn't matter what color
your skin is doesn't matter what race
you are what ethnicity you are you
deserve to be the hero of the story my
first memory of filming brooklyn
nine-nine i can't remember anything
about filming the pilot except there was
conversation that took place very late
at night when we were shooting the pilot
it was myself joe latrulio melissa
fumero and andy samberg and we were all
sitting around a table at craft services
outside waiting for them to set up a
shot it was dark we were all tired but
we were psyched because we were filming
a pilot and andy sort of said well
get used to these faces we're gonna be
seeing them for the next seven years and
we all kind of laughed because that's
what we wanted to have happen but it was
a big dream and then it actually came
true
my first impressions of my brooklyn
nine-nine cast members andy sandberg so
smart joe latrulio so funny melissa
romero so kind and generous terry crews
so
much bigger in real life than you would
ever imagine andre brauer wow such a
genius oh my gosh very nervous to be
around you chelsea peretti absolute
comic genius one of the greats the first
role that i really wanted and didn't get
was the leading lady in my middle school
production of idaho the potatoes but
they just won't grow i did not book that
role unfortunately i did book the role
of the villain i dressed in a top hat
and a handlebar mustache and the next
day after the entire school had seen the
play in science class willie rivera
shout out will rivera came up to me and
said your brother was so funny in the
play yesterday i don't have a brother i
didn't know what to say because i had a
huge crush on willy rivera shout out
will rivera so i just sort of sat in my
chair and was like thank you i'll will
tell him that you liked him and i kind
of knew i was like oh wow if i fooled
willie rivera who's been sitting like
two seats behind me in science class for
this entire year into thinking that i
was somebody completely different maybe
i can fool more people maybe i should be
an actor first scene i filmed for in the
heights all of in the heights was sort
of kind of this
mystical colorful magical blur and then
it was like
okay we did it it happened fast my first
kiss was not cool it was awkward and
sloppy nobody knew what they were doing
with their tongues it was regrettable
and yet necessary the first album that i
ever purchased with my own money was
tony braxton's secrets because unbreak
my heart is a jam you cannot tell me
it's not her work on that is incredible
tony braxton you're an icon in the
legend
[Music]
the first job i ever had was babysitting
i think well i don't know why anyone
trusted like 14 15 year old me to watch
a baby i would never
i have a baby now and i would never
trust a 14 year old
imagine the first time i was really
deeply starstruck i was backstage
at rockefeller center dolly parton was
doing a morning show she sang from her
new album and then she walked by me in
the hallway like i saw her coming i
understood what it meant to be
starstruck in that moment because it
what it truly was like i mean my hands
are sweating right now thinking about it
love her with every part of my soul and
there she was like two feet in front of
me and like i made eye contact with her
and i was like this is your shot you
have to tell her you have to there she
goes she's walking away oh no she's gone
and that was it i never got to say
anything to her and i bet i never will
thank you buzzfeed you can check out
encanto in theaters on november 24th
[Music]
wow
[Music]